ich habe mit 200000 € ein Startup
gegründet und wenige Monate nach der
Gründung stehe ich vor dem Team von MR
Beast um ihn von dieser Idee zu erzählen
wie es dazu gekommen ist erfahrt ihr in
dieser Folge von
stup okay aber eins nach dem anderen
nach der Gründung beim Notar sitzen wir
im Prinzip vor einem weißen Blatt Papier
und müssen aus dem Nichts eine App
Gestalten in der sich die Nutzer so
intuitiv und einfach bewegen können wie
sie es von anderen Apps und z.B Social
Media Plattform gewöhnt sind passiert
das nicht sieht die App oder fühlt sich
die App wie ein Fremdkörper an und das
ist das allerletzte was wir wollen dazu
muss die gesamte Funktionalität im
Hintergrund sicher und konstant laufen
wir können uns natürlich in keinem Fall
irgendeinen Ausfall erlauben wir
brauchen einen coolen Namen und ein
cooles Logo dass die Idee der App in
wenigen Bruchteilen von Sekunden allen
Leuten klar werden lässt wir müssen uns
im lohnbuchhtung die gesamte Bürokratie
und so weiter kümmern und das irgendwie
jeder für sich und doch alle zusammen
glücklicherweise ist jeder der vier
Gründer von uns ist schon gewohnt den
ganzen Tag am Rechner zu sitzen und
durchzuarbeiten und sich völlig in
irgendeiner neuen Idee oder Aufgabe zu
verlieren deseswegen das eigentlich
ziemlich gut geklappt hat bei einem
freelance UI Designer haben unsere
Anforderungen Moodboards Vorstellung und
so weiter abgegeben um von ihm eine
erste grobe Richtung für die App zu
bekommen nachdem wir eine Richtung
gefunden haben die allen gepasst hat hat
Tilman anfangen können das ganze
Frontend mit Leben und Design über
Wochen und Monate füllen zu können damit
es nicht nur gut aussieht sondern es
tatsächlich auch funktioniert und sich
gut anfühlt matthias hat sich um das
gesamte Backend gekümmert also die
Infrastruktur um Shops schlussendlich
wirklich an unseren Shop anbinden zu
könen und z.B die ausge Provision
zwischen euch dem Nutzer und dem Creator
aufteilen zu können die Daten zu
verwalten und sie richtig auszuwerten
dominik hat sich darum gekümmert
Onlineshops von unserer Idee zu erzählen
und sie tatsächlich zu überzeugen Teil
dieser Idee zu sein natürlich an allen
anderen Stellen auch die Bude am Laufen
gehalten er ist eben CEO und muss quasi
Überblick über alles haben für mich hieß
es an influencer Kollegen herantreten
und sie von der Idee überzeugen ein
Problem hatte aber jeder von uns alle
aus dem Team waren darauf angewiesen
dass irgendjemand anders aus dem Team
mit seiner Aufgabe fertig wurde oder
zumindest est bedeutend weiterkam was
einen absoluten Teufelskreislauf ergeben
hat und kurz das Gefühl in mir ausgelöst
hat dass das Problem schon unsere App
zum Scheitern verurteilt hat es gab also
quasi ein Henne Problem was war zuerst
da der Shop oder der Creator oder das
Backend oder das Frontend insgesamt
waren wir alle auf das fertig werden von
jemand anderem angewiesen was eben
diesen Teufelskreislauf ergeben hat
gleichzeitig gilt es für jeden von uns
die langfristigen Ziele im Blick zu
behalten und auch schon die Weichen
dafür zuustellen wir sind so viel mehr
als die Basisfunktionalität die jetzt
direkt zum as verfügbar ist nämlich
Cashback zwischen Nutzer und Creator
aufzuteilen wir wollen die App zu einem
absoluten powerpar Tool entwickeln was
im Optimalfall bedeutet dass sie euer
täglicher Begleiter zum Thema Sparen
wird was genau das bedeutet erfahrt ihr
natürlich alles bald vor allem aber
leben wir von der Community nämlich euch
und der Community die sich auf savit
bilden wird ähnlich wie beim
Wohnungsprojekt sind wir auf Feedback
angewiesen auf eure Ideen auf Dinge die
ihr umgesetzt sehen wollt und genau das
brauchen wir wir haben eben durch euch
die unheimliche Kraft der
Schwarmintelligenz und das wollen wir
nutzen um am Ende das beste Tool für
Shops Creator und Nutzer zu bauen und
trotz alledem sind wir nach wie vor ein
Startup es kann also sein dass direkt
zum Launch der App nicht alles 100% ist
lasst uns da an einem Strang ziehen und
gebt uns sofort Bescheid wenn euch
irgendwas auffällt und deswegen will ich
direkt auf ein Thema eingehen das im
letzten Video in den Kommentaren aufkam
ihr bekommt bei uns nämlich nicht
weniger Cashback als bei konventionellen
schon bestehenden Plattformen nur weil
wir einen Teil der Provision an Creator
auszahlen der Teil den wir nämlich an
Creator auszahlen ist der den schon
bestehende Plattformen sich entweder in
die Tasche stecken oder für sehr teure
konventionelle Werbung bezahlen um
Nutzer auf die Plattform zu bekommen
diese Werbung kostet natürlich auch eine
Menge Geld und wird euch dem Nutzer auf
den schon bestehenden Plattform vom
Cashback abgezogen wir fahren einen
anderen Ansatz und beteiligen alle an
dem Cashback also auch die Creator die
euch den Nutzer auf unsere Plattform
bringen und bezahlen so eben kein Geld
für konventionelle Werbung was viel
nicht klar ist ist das Onlineshops bei
Cashback Plattform auch noch für ihre
Platzierungen und Ihr Ranking bezahlen
also je nachdem wo sie angezeigt werden
z.
während der Black Friday Woche eben ganz
oben in dem prominenten Platz angezeigt
zu werden das ist für uns auch eine
Möglichkeit um quasi direkt zum Start
Geld mit der App zu verdienen am Anfang
geht es uns und so ehrlich muss ich sein
aber vor allem darum möglichst viele
Leute auf die Plattform zu bekommen
ihnen save zu zeigen und dadurch einen
besseren Hebel zu haben um größere
bessere Deals für alle von uns zu
bekommen und die nächsten steps besser
machen zu können wir sind ein kleines
Startup und können natürlich nicht von
großen Onlineshops irgendwelche mega
Deals verlangen wenn wir nur wenige
Nutzer haben schweige denn irgendwann in
den Offline Markt schaffen wenn wir nur
10 000 Nutzer haben zurück zur
Entwicklung das Problem ist nämlich
zumindest in meinem Fall dass ich mich
ja gar nicht ein 100% auf SAV it
kontrollieren kann weil ich noch ein
zweites Startup habe ein Startup indem
ich diese Youtube Videos hier mache wo
ich fünf Angestellte in Köln sitzen habe
die Leitung brauchen die Aufgaben
brauchen und natürlich eine Menge
Zuschauer die darauf warten irgendwelche
im besten Fall sehr guten Videos von mir
zu sehen weil die Zeit schneller vergeht
als man gucken kann habe ich mich
irgendwann in Frankfurt aM Flughafen
wiedergefunden um von dort für einen
Monat nach Kanada zu fliegen um seven
VSS wild mitzupoduzieren natürlich kann
ich mit 10 000 km entfnung und einer
Menge Zeitverschiebung deutlich
schlechter an diesen Projekten
weiterarbeiten warum s vs wild und die
Zeit vor Ort aber am Ende doch
entscheidend dafür war dass das alles
hier so wunderbar funktioniert erfahrt
ihr in der nächsten Folge für Dominik
und mich hieß es im Entwicklungsprozess
also Klinken putzen Klinken putzen
Klinken putzen Leuten das Projekt näher
bringen und wirklich Vertrauen aufbauen
und klar im deutschen Rahmen kann ich
unheimlich viele Creator Partner
onlinehops und so weiter Erreichen der
kennt den der kennt den und so weiter
das endet aber mit den Grenzen vom
deutschsprachigen Raum will ich über
diese deutschsprachigen Grenzen hinaus
aber die größten was rede ich den
größten Creator erreichen müsste
wirklich ein Wunder passieren und was
soll ich sagen genau dieses Wunder ist
passiert eines Abends erilte uns eine
E-Mail wir sind für den webvpreis
nominiert erstmal nichts Besonderes
weiter unten in der Mail aber ein Zusatz
neben der Nominierung laden wir Dich
auch herzlich zu einem persönlichen
Treffen mit Chucky aus dem Mr Beast Team
ein um YouTube und Social Media
zuquatchen chucky ist aber nicht
irgendeiner von den hunderten von
Mitarbeitern von MR Beast sondern und
vielleicht habt ihr davon schon mal
gehört der MR Beast Clone jemand der ein
ähnliches Beurteilungsvermögen hat ein
ähnliches Feuer für Social Media und
Content und jahrelanger Freund von Jimmy
das Problem Chucky hat keine Ahnung wer
ich bin nur wenig Zeit und dadurch auch
nur begrenzt Aufmerksamkeit irgendwann
hatte ich die Idee zu fragen was für ihn
und für das MR Beast Team das größte
Problem von internationalem Content ist
zu meinem Glück hat er geantwortet dass
Vermarktung von internationalem Content
über verschiedene Sprachen und Regionen
hinweg gerade das größte Problem von MR
Beast sei und ich habe wie in dem Film
die coole Antwort
gegebenc
glücklicherweise hat er die
Vorgehensweise mit unserem Tool und den
USP erkannt und mich glücklicherweise an
Manager von MR beast von night Media
einem der größten Creator Netzwerke oder
Creator Managements verwiesen wo sich
mit Sicherheit in den nächsten Wochen
noch was ergeben kann überhaupt aber die
Möglichkeit zu haben jemandem aus dem Mr
Beast Team jemandem internationalen
davon zu erzählen wirklich zu erfahren
dass es tatsächlich das Problem ist das
ist eins der größten Probleme ist dass
wir mit unserer App angehen war eine
absolute Genugtuung hat uns komplett in
unserem Weg bestärkt und war einfach
absolut Toper Erfahrung also vielen Dank
noch mal an den Web videopreis der das
überhaupt möglich gemacht hat ein
Problem hat so eine
Internationalisierung aber und das ist
das kostet richtig Kohle genauso wie so
ziemlich alles andere was mit Startup zu
tun hat und was man entwickeln und
umsetzen will und deswegen mussten wir
uns relativ schnell auch auf die Suche
nach neuem Geld machen Geld das über
mein Investment von über 200.000 €
hinaus geht und glücklicherweise haben
wir da ein paar richtig gute Optionen
gefunden ganz grundsätzlich hat man
neben privatem Investment in so eine
Idee ein paar verschiedene Optionen man
kann zur Bank gehen und sich einen
Kredit holen man leih sich Geld bezahlt
eine Gebühr nämlich Zinsen für dieses
Geld und bezahlt das gesamte Geld
irgendwann wieder zurück Option 2 ein
Investment man sucht jemanden der die
Idee für so gut hält dass er bereit ist
Geld in die Firma zu stecken und dafür
Anteile von dem Unternehmen
zurückzubekommen und option 3 und genau
darum geht es jetzt Förderung Geld vom
Staat von der Europäischen Union oder
vom Land von wem auch immer die ein
Interesse daran haben neue Firmen
wachsen zu sehen neue Firmen bedeuten
nämlich ganz einfach neue Jobs mehr
Steuereinnahmen und so weiter und
deswegen fördern sie weil das gesamte
förderungsthema aber absolut
undurchsichtig ist haben wir es erstmal
links liegen lassen bis eine Mail von
Tobias Koch von considerate erhalten
haben der uns seine Hilfe angeboten hat
in einem kurzen Gespräch weil Tobias
absoluter Experte ist konnte er sofort
feststellen dass einige Teilbereiche
unserer Idee förderfähig sind und das
obwohl wir schon gegründet hatten also
Förderung rückwirkend einzuholen sind
klar besser ist es wenn man sich sofort
darum kümmert und mehr Möglichkeiten hat
man wenn man sich sofort darum kümmert
aber auch rückwirkend gibt es
Möglichkeiten was mega geil ist ob ihr
eure Idee oder eure Firma förderfähig
sind könnt ihr ganz einfach über den
Link in der Videobeschreibung und die
Hilfe von Tobias herausfinden und dabei
ist es völlig egal ob ihr ein Startup
seid ein Startup Gründen wollt oder ihr
vielleicht sogar schon ein sehr großes
wirklich rentables Unternehmen seid weil
z.B auch riesenfirmen wie Audi oder all
die anderen DAX Konzerne profitieren
unheimlich stark von Förderung wie viel
dabei tatsächlich für uns rumkommt
erfahrt ihr sobald wir es erfahren der
ganze Prozess zieht sich einfach immer
ein bisschen und ist mit unheim für
Bürokratie verbunden deswegen wir super
happy sind da Unterstützung zu bekommen
was in den letzten Tagen und Wochen vor
dem Launch alles noch passiert ist
abseits davon dass wirklich jeder von
uns komplett krank geworden ist erfahrt
ja am Sonntag am selben Tag an dem auch
die App launchtcht wie wir unsere
Firmenbewertung von ein paar Millionen
Euro bekommen haben und so weiter also
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
und seid mit uns am Sonntag dabei wenn
SAV it tatsächlich Releas auch auf
diesem Wege noch mal vielen Dank für
euren Support das wirklich geisteskrank
und viel besser als ich mir hätte
vorstellen können wir sehen uns am
Sonntag zum nächsten Video und zum
Launch der macht es gut bis dahin Ciao
Tschüss bis
Sonntag